When
you've
been
in
some
situations
where
life
wasn't
going
your
way
what
were
some
of
the
ways
tools
the
words
of
wisdom
that
helped
keep
you
going
when
times
were
tough
There
have
been
a
couple
bear
markets
for
me
before
and
every
time
you
hit
that
low
point
where
you
sort
of
think
like
what's
going
on
I
think
ultimately
it's
just
realizing
that
if
what
you're
building
has
some
level
of
real
impact
on
society
market
cycles
come
and
go
eventually
the
market
will
come
back
And
as
long
you've
built
something
real
the
bear
market
is
the
best
time
because
there's
less
people
fighting
for
attention
there's
less
hype
cycles
narrative
So
people
building
real
infrastructure
really
do
have
the
time
to
shine